it wasn't just digital de-aging that
made Harrison Ford look 40 years younger
in the opening of Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny crew members also made a
special mask that lives firmly in The
Uncanny Valley stick around for a closer
look at this creepy creation
prior to the release of Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny there was a lot
of talk about how the film would use the
Aging technology for the sequence at the
beginning of the film set during World
War II the goal was to make Indiana
Jones look similar to how he did in
Raiders of the Lost Ark and the digital
effect was mostly a success while
there's ample CGI on display throughout
the rest of the movie there are also
good old-fashioned practical effects
including a realistic mask that may just
haunt your dreams on Instagram special
effects artist Waldo Mason shared images
of a stunt mask used in dial of Destiny
while the realistic skin texture makes
the mask somewhat uncanny on its own it
doesn't seem all that freaky but it's a
different story when we see it in action
Mason included two pictures of a stunt
double wearing the mask on top of
motorcycle and standing in an office the
use of stun doubles with prosthetics is
nothing new for action movies but out of
context the mask is definitely getting a
strong reaction from Indiana Jones fans
there's been no shortage of Pop Culture
similarities pointed out on social media
several people compared it to Michael
Myers mask from the Halloween movies and
one to the user even wrote it definitely
looks like something from Dawn of the
Dead But the comparisons included the
realistic disguises of the mission
impossible franchise and a mask that
Ryan Gosling wears at one point in Drive
however the most common reference seems
to have been to the prank show sketch
from Netflix's I think you should leave
which to pick star Tim Robinson covered
in so many Prosthetics that he loses his
calls in a shopping mall many fans of
the show were quick to point out that
Indiana Jones mask resemblance of the
Troublemaker Carl Havoc I'm not doing it
I don't even want to be around anymore
despite all the jokes some film
enthusiasts pointed out that they were
happy to see practical effects being
used in 2023 another Twitter user stated
long proud history of these in movies
I'll take these over CGI any day because
at least the brain knows it's a real
person in the shot it's great to see
stunt performers continuing to get work
in movies at this scale even if Harrison
Ford thinks they could back off every
now and then stunts man and stunt women
play crucial roles on film sets they
often do the difficult scenes an actor
can't risk doing as an injury would shut
down production with Harrison Ford being
an octogenarian there's little doubt
that stun performers were needed
occasionally to help with some of his
scenes however Ford still did plenty on
his own and even thought the stun
workers were sometimes doing too much
when speaking with Esquire Ford
discussed one scene in which he thought
too many people were trying to help him
off of a horse as he described it I
looked down on their three stun guys
there making sure I don't fall off the
stir up they said oh we were just afraid
because we thought you know when Baba
Baba and I said leave me the alone
I'm an old man Ford also said that he
wanted to actually look like an older
man getting off a horse after all
indie's advanced stage is a pretty
important part of his story in dial of
Destiny a lot of hard work goes into
making a movie someone needs to make a
convincing Harrison Ford mask someone
else needs to wear that mask a third
person that's a shooter in action and a
whole team of people have to fix any
present issues in post it's all for the
greater good of bringing a story to the
big screen even if the mask looks so hot
and uncomfortable that the person
wearing it would probably want to rip it
off or having an existential crisis